all right boys sorry about the the rant
style that this video is gonna be in but
you know me if brian rose is involved we
gotta talk about it and he recently
published
pandemic ii now if you guys remember
pandemic one
it's a viral little uh documentary i say
that very generously
i mean it's just like a one-sided piece
and pandemic two they basically say the
same stuff
and i want to talk about three things in
it and because i'm not trying to
convince anybody i've given up on trying
to do that
so instead i just want to offer some
things to think about while
you you mull over this uh pandemic too
if you've seen it
if you haven't seen it uh it's on the
digital freedom platform i though
i don't recommend you go there because
you're gonna have to put in your email
address for brian rose to collect
and then it'll advertise scams to you
forever but uh so don't so don't do that
you know there are other sites you can
probably watch it on
but let me just say a few things about
it okay to start off and the director
mickey willis
so first of all it's well edited look
nobody's gonna accuse this guy mickey
willis of not being a good editor
and clipping things together i mean he
talks a lot about how powerful narrative
is and i actually totally agree with
them
our lives are shaped and guided by
stories
the stories we're told become the
stories we tell
the more we hear them the more we
believe them
you can make things look a certain way
if you just present the evidence
in a certain light and i'm gonna agree
with them on one thing look big pharma
does suck
everybody's gonna tell you that doctors
will tell you that uh
big pharma will probably tell you that
and i'll definitely tell you that big
pharma has huge problems corruption
greed
conflicts of interest a hundred percent
anyone who tells you otherwise
is lying that being said the movie
doesn't answer
what i think is the most important
question which is okay
so now what like all right mickey willis
we we hear what you
we hear your point like you don't like
big pharma so now what
what are you gonna go back to to chewing
like leaves
i mean medicine is overall a good thing
most people think that
like when you see longevity over time
we're just
getting older and older because the
medicine works better and better
it's like the general curve of humanity
and it's sort of like
you know the the people who are upset at
the cops right now
because yeah you can point to how
corrupt cops are
and everyone who's saying would agree
with you you can point to bad cops
a hundred percent you can even say that
even the system
of training cops and all these things is
inherently flawed
just like you could argue that big
pharma is inherently flawed
agreed but then the question eventually
becomes all right you criticized you
criticized you criticized
but then now what are you calling to
defund the police are you calling
to defund big pharma so what what are
you going to use
i mean right when you're in trouble who
are you going to call
and this is the part where plan dimitt
completely falls flat on its face
okay besides all the conspiracy
mongering because they point out
big farm is corrupt which i like i agree
i'm with them there and then they're
like
yeah and it's all this big plot okay you
lose me there
but anyways what's what's your big plan
mickey willis like he offers this trite
thing about
we've replaced medicines that help with
drugs that harm he literally says that
in the like
documentary with no irony we trade
medicines that heal
[Music]
for drugs that harm dude
what do you want us to go back to
chewing oregano
you want us to go back to uh you know
dosing with rosemary
just like what do you want us to do my
man look there's a reason
we don't all chew mushrooms from the
wilderness anymore it's because
we had a better idea medicines used for
thousands of years were suddenly
classified as
alternative we've replaced these old
drugs and called them alternative
medicine because
we now have better drugs that work
better are there problems sure
but you just have to take one look at
human
lifespan and you'll realize that
medicine has been
on the balance a very very good thing
so that really pisses me off because it
just seems like he's complaining a bunch
he's railing against the system which
like yeah
i get it i'm with him up to a certain
point about like
big pharma having problems and then he
just gets to like the defund the pharma
kind of thing
and that's where he loses me like let's
all go back to nature
nah bro sure there's problems with
opiates but i don't want to go back to
the day that when there weren't pain
killers
their problems with all sorts of things
but that you would not
replace that problem with like the old
problem the new problems better than the
old problem
is the point that i'm getting at so
anyway that's to address the first thing
the second thing is i want to talk about
good old bribry i've already touched on
this in a second but look dude this guy
is not out
to get the truth out right he's an
opportunist and it's time you guys wake
up to this
land and reel in order to access this
so-called pandemic first of all
they could have used bit shoot all along
as the digital freedom platform i don't
want to belabor this because i've made a
whole series of videos on it's
one of these i'll post it but the point
is he could have used a free platform
instead he took
millions of dollars of his subscribers
money and then made his own digital
freedom platform where the big catch is
you have to put in your email address
before you can watch
anything on his website which means he's
collected literally millions of email
addresses
which now he sends his little newsletter
to and uh he
sells out his little email list to
people who are selling scams
right we've already talked about this
with the crypto guy tikka tuary
which london reel was advertising but
the other thing is look it's not just me
who thinks he's a scammer or an
opportunist people from london reel have
reached out to me
to tell me what what kind of guy this is
but even people who haven't reached out
like uh
london reel's business partner nick i
don't know if you guys know this but
london real wasn't started
as a sole proprietorship it was started
as a duo what happened to nick where's
nick brian
he's nowhere to be seen or just take a
look at uh peter sage
you know brian rose is happy to have him
on when peter sage was bringing in the
traffic
right but then peter sage goes to jail
he had this whole scandal
and when peter sage becomes a hot potato
what does brian do
does he stick his neck out for the guy
does he say hey i might disagree with
you
but i'll defend to the death you're
right to say it no
he drops him like a hot potato and
removes him from his platform and
pretends like he doesn't know him people
have literally been calling this guy out
for
over six years this is an interview what
you're about to see
is an interview from six years ago
where joey diaz i don't know if you guys
know who that is he's from like the joe
rogan universe of characters
he calls this guy out from all the way
back then it was this is when brian rose
was doing some shady marketing and then
he got called out on it and he blamed it
on his interns that's the that's the
background that's what i got pissed off
about
because claim responsibility even till
today he put up a youtube video on
monday
saying that it was his [ __ ] interns
that guy you'd never want to do business
with a guy like that that cannot claim
responsibility
that is a [ __ ] that's the type of guy
that'll leave you in a [ __ ] lurch
i've been saying this for a long time
but apparently joey diaz
has been saying it for much longer this
guy has shown his true color time and
time again
so okay we've talked about the director
of the film his whole thing of like
let's go all go back to plants which i
think is stupid we've talked about the
guy promoting the film
brian rose and his very sketchy history
shall we say but now i want to just tell
you my general beef with alternative
medicine because look
once again i have no problems copying to
the fact that big pharma sucks
that needs reform it needs to be changed
but what i hate is these alternative
medicine people
pretending to be the good guys and all
they want to do is sell you something
they just want a piece of the pie and so
they're calling out calling out
big pharma but ultimately guess what hey
they want to slice and they want to play
like they're some tiny guy right they
want to play like
hey we're david fighting against goliath
but dude look at the truth man
the global complimentary and alternative
medicine market size was projected at
69.2 billion dollars okay
this is not some tiny industry
fighting for survival it's a billion
dollar industry
they don't they won't tell you that of
course because you know you're not gonna
feel bad
for a billion dollar industry versus a
billion dollar industry
but that's actually what's going on it's
big pharma versus
big natural or big alternative or
something like that
and these people have the same narrative
every time it's predictable
look think about what you saw in
pandemic okay what did you see you saw
somebody saying there's a giant
conspiracy
to hide the true cures and uh oh but
don't blame your doctor because they're
just indoctrinated right
this is not an indictment against
doctors more than anyone
they are under the stranglehold of the
single largest lobbying power in
washington
now let's go over to uh my long list of
health scams that i've accumulated over
the years
which i keep in a little file on the
google drive
so this is uh american health
underground whistleblower reveals seven
deadly drugs the government wants
you to swallow now you could basically
put this in the plandemic film and no
one would be shocked at all no one would
be surprised
okay let's let's see what we're reading
here dear reader what you're about to
read will likely make you mad but it
also could save your life
okay so let's get back to down to the
part where they start blaming big pharma
oh okay here it is
here's the worst part while the fda
pushes big pharma's poison profit pills
a shroud of secrecy is thrown over
powerful natural cures
hmm remind you of anyone we trade
medicines that heal
[Music]
for drugs that harm but now let's hear
about your doctor right
because it's not your doctor's fault is
it no of course not of course not
make no mistake your doctor probably
can't tell you about any of the secrets
you'll find in this book
it's not his fault i'll explain in a
moment now i want to pause here and
explain what
the strategy is here so these people
know persuasion inside out
so what do they know well they know that
number one
you're very likely to believe the idea
that big pharma is corrupt and they're
hiding something because
you already know that big farm is
corrupt so the only logical leap they
have to make you believe is
they're hiding something right but what
you won't believe
is that your doctor's corrupt guys
because you know your doctor
and you're much more likely to believe
that a shadowy cabal is corrupt
than this guy that you know and you know
that your doctor's a well-intentioned
guy
so they know you will believe him and so
what can they do
they can't convince you that your
doctor's corrupt because you know that's
not true
so what do they have to tell you you
know they have to tell you that it's not
your doctor's fault
your doctor is just a well-meaning idiot
you know it's not like he went to years
and years of schooling and
can think for himself no he's a brain
dead idiot who's been brainwashed by big
pharma
so they tell you your family doctor's
probably a good guy but he's just too
stupid to understand the truth
all right so after we get done with that
what's the actual point here what's the
actual point well
is it just to get the word out no it's
to sell you something
look dr king's natural medicine sciatic
nerve formula 19.99 ooh baby got some
pills
34.99 this is at the bottom of this
thing telling you to
all these secrets have been hidden from
you 49.95 so
let me recap they tell you big farm is
out to get you they're greedy
your doctor doesn't know about it
because he's stupid now pay us 49.95 for
the trouble
and we'll solve all your problems and
this is what alternative health does now
do they have any studies to back up the
fact that they're claiming to cure
cancer alzheimer's heart disease
no they don't need to because they're
alternative medicine but you're probably
saying yourself stephen that's just one
example right that's just one example so
what
these things have this in common that
doesn't show a pattern
okay well let's check out another one
here's the blacklist true cures for the
12 deadliest diseases known to mankind
okay here we go
so uh okay we get into it let's see they
won't
let us have the cures so when do they
blame big pharma oh okay it's in the
introduction our medical establishment
does everything in its power to keep
them away from you what are they keeping
away
cures for cancer heart disease diabetes
asthma allergies pain cataracts
osteoporosis arthritis fatigue
alzheimer's and more
oh because they do exist they're just
being hidden from you and but you know
by the cabal but don't blame your family
doctor look
watch this i'll show you it's not your
doctor's fault oh look at this don't
blame your doctor it's in the same
paragraph i missed it
you see this powerful multi-billion
dollar industry controls
all medical information they effectively
shut down all descent
so once again big pharma controls all
medical information but don't blame your
doctor
because big pharma is evil but your
doctor's not evil he's just stupid he
just doesn't understand
and uh you know this person this this
rogue
this rogue doctor you know remind you of
anybody this
whistleblower oh wow whistleblower oh
interesting okay so this whistleblower
is talking to us
sounds familiar sounds like judy
mykovitz okay now let's say we want the
uncensored truth about natural cures are
they going to give it to us for free
are they are they are they doing it
because they love us
oops nope you gotta buy something oh
yeah doesn't that always
hit you in the gut when it comes at the
end there of a wait there's more here's
another
one the story we're about to hear was
denied by our own united states
government dr gerhauser saying he's
going to cure cancer the true
cure for cancer okay well why haven't
you heard of it before
the answer you've heard of before it's
because
the trillion dollar big farm industry is
a very willing partner in crime with our
own united states government
the big pharma owns the fda
but don't worry it's not your doctor's
fault haha look at it he means well no
question about it
but he's simply not taught about it
because that's not the way our medical
system
works he doesn't know about the warburg
method you don't know about the warframe
method dude
it's the way you truly cure cancer i
mean it's just the way it is
now why do i show you guys all this it's
because i want to show you that this
this argument
that is being made in pandemic ad
nauseum that
big farm is bad oregano cures are good
it's as old as time this is not an
indictment against doctors
more than anyone they are under the
stranglehold of the single largest
lobbying power in washington
and what you find at the end of the day
is that these people who are promoting
these things
are never themselves without interest so
while you may not leave this video
thinking that big pharma is great
that's fine i don't expect to convince a
lot of you and honestly
big pharma has a lot of problems what i
want you to leave this
also knowing is that hey these people
making the plandemic too
these people making these uh alternative
medicine things like oh come
come join my alternative medicine thing
i'm the i'm the true guy with
pure interests no they don't
and actually the difference between a
doctor and alternative medicine is your
doctor can't just
claim to cure cancer when he can't cure
your cancer whereas alternative medicine
they can
and now what i want to show you is
something you'll never see anywhere else
and the only reason i have it is because
i know a bunch of copywriters i know
people who write this alternative stuff
and they've let me in behind the scenes
of their industry
the people who are sick of this stuff
and they let me access
to not only the sales letters that
you're reading but actually
their notation on the sales letters so
you can get an
inside look into what the mind of these
people are
so let me show you something that will
blow your mind because
you know i know you think all these guys
are well-meaning they're the good guys
and big farmers the bad guys i want to
show you something that will
literally knock you off your socks i
think
this is something called did our creator
encode a cancer cure in the 859th
page on the ancient bible okay spoiler
alert no
no he didn't okay and this makes me mad
because they're preying on people of
faith
because they know they're more likely to
be open-minded to these alternative
therapies
and they prey on it by basically going
hey i'm i'm a christian guy too they
load it up with
christian language to try to get them to
buy because that's ultimately what it's
about it's about money
don't you get it it's about getting the
money if they can't get your money they
don't care
right they care if they can take your
money so okay let's hear about it
did could the holy bible contain the
ziggurat eliminating the worst disease
facing mankind
oh yeah it's called the matthew 4 pro
cancer protocol
okay the well-worn pages of your family
bible had have held the secrets to these
miracles all along now i'm gonna spoil
the ending for you look at that payment
options is at the bottom of the page
after you read
what is essentially uh i don't know like
30 pages this is where you get to
payment
payment because you got to pay us right
pay your fellow christian
but look with that setting that aside
let's dissect what this is doing okay
these people like i said they know what
they're doing they're playing to your
biases
so look at this right here did our
creator encode can secure in the bible
and this is someone's notes
as a copywriter so here's a note
identify with christians
god-fearing patriotic americans and what
they're talking about right here is
the the headline did our creator encode
a cancer cure on the 859th page
of the ancient bible so they know what
is our target for selling our whatever
our
shill thing is today but check it out
let's read on okay so they call it a
healing code and it's hidden on the 859
page of the king james bible so
they're trying to get authority with you
so they're saying that okay so then they
get into the
the nightmare stories with absolutely
nothing to lose who's given the matthew
4 protocol to try and
doesn't have any supplements he was able
to do it safely on his own
and they put a note no drugs because
people don't like taking drugs and they
know that so they know okay this is
we're convincing them we're convincing
them we're convincing them we're
convincing them
but this is the stuff that pisses me off
they purposely
put in little tags to make you identify
and more likely to buy
but do you think these people actually
believe this stuff like
i don't actually think i mean maybe
they're christian but
are they though i would not be surprised
if they're not
but check this out okay they put in this
guy mark
stingler or his appearance is on the 700
club and then below it he goes christian
mark stingler has become one of the most
trusted evangelists
authority he's also a devout christian
and has studied the bible in great depth
religion so these people in the
alternative health movement
they're not your heroes they're people
preying on you even worse than big
pharma
they're not only preying on you for
money because you're desperate i mean at
least in the case of big pharma they're
using drugs that have been proven to
work
in the case of these guys they're
selling you snake oil and they're
selling it to you
using your biases and what you know so
if if you're a christian
they want to appeal to you actually if
you're a muslim they probably want to
appeal to you too they'll write you a
whole thing about how
muhammad found the cure for cancer if
you're an atheist they'll tell you how
the skeptics found a cure for cancer
in other words they'll tell you anything
you want to know
and then they'll tell you it's all a big
farmer's fault you haven't been cured
but it's not your doctor's fault because
it's not their fault
they're just stupid but if you'll just
pay us if you just pay us don't you get
it it's all about
paying them and look with all that said
how it's all about ending up
selling you something let's skip forward
to the end of pandemic 2. what's at the
end of pandemic 2. and look finally
we have the london reel academy so if we
can help with anything
that you need whether that means
starting a business or starting a
podcast or anything
that's what we do we're specialists at
that and i would really love to help you
all out so
he'd love to help you just fork over
that credit card
for the cool cool price of thousands of
dollars for his
coaching right because you can trust
brian rose
he's a man of character he's the one who
revealed to you the truth
so open up your wallet fork over some
cash
and don't forget to smash like and
subscribe
thank you
[Music]
comes along